one of the owners of inventors of Google
said that that's how it was invented
Google Images there was so much traffic
trying to find that dress that they
invented it so people could find it hi
I'm Jennifer Lopez and these are some of
my biggest moments Selena
[Music]
playing the role of Selena at the time
was a great thing because I was so young
I was my 20s with my early 20s and even
though I knew was a huge responsibility
and I wanted to do a great job there's
kind of an ignorance that you have at
that age like how big it would be and
how big of a responsibility it was you
know and how people were looking at it I
just kind of just delved into the
character and into getting to know her
as much as I could and watching every
piece of tape I could find and spending
as much time as I could with her family
who were very generous to let me get to
know them and they were still in a lot
of grief she had just died two years
before so it was a very special project
obviously in my life that whole project
was full of big moments auditioning for
it was a big moment screen testing for
it you know five auditions later was a
big moment getting the part was a big
moment doing the press conference for
getting the part with a big moment and
then the premiere obviously and and it
being you know successful that it was
all amazing Selena was a natural
performer she never took dance classes
or anything she was a singer and she
happened to be a natural dancer and a
great performer so the way she performs
is very different than what I do now but
I loved learning from her her ease on
stage and her looseness was something
that I had to learn because I was such a
choreograph dancer that part of it was a
real blessing that I got to kind of walk
in her shoes and dance in her shoes in
her way there are certain things that
really define who you are as an artist
and I feel like that was something that
really defined a time in my life things
that define your life is an artist also
define you as a person and there's a
part of you that learns and grows and
the best characters that you do and I
feel like Selena was that for me
Jenny from the block the song and how
many times I've performed it since I put
it out oh my god I mean all the time
many hundreds of times the lyrics to
that song are still relevant to my life
now because growing up in the Bronx
really defined Who I am it was written
for me by someone else who was from New
York as well and who understands that
when you grow up in New York and you
grow up in the Bronx that there is a
part of that that never leaves you
growing up in the Bronx and being that
person from the block is really a huge
part of who I am still today I just
think you know the big moment for that
is whenever anybody comes up to me and
calls me Jenny from the block like oh my
god and they get excited and they don't
go there's JLo or there's oh my god
there's Jennifer Lopez the actress they
relate they're like you're one of us
some people just really go to that
persona they're Versace dress I didn't
have anything to wear for the Grammys
and my stylist showed up with two
dresses and the green dress was one of
them I tried on both dresses and that
wound up being the one I wore that night
I think you know the next morning I was
on the cover of USA Today and under
cover of the papers you know I knew I
was like oh okay this hit a chord with
people mmm my confidence in wearing such
provocative clothing I don't see it as
provocative I see it as sensual and sexy
and beautiful
well Donatella was doing a 20-year
anniversary collection of that print
which became a very big print for them
over the years and she was gonna do a
whole show dedicated to that print and
reinventing that print and she asked me
to walk I said yeah of course you know
we've been very close for a long time
now so American Idol I had just had my
babies they were 2 years old and I got a
call from my
Benny Medina and he said Simon Fuller
wanted to come over who was the inventor
of American Idol and he said you know
that some people were gonna be leaving
and they were gonna be revamping the
show and he asked if I would want to be
a judge on American Idol they came over
with an envelope you know with an offer
in it and it was a good offer I decided
that I would do it at first maybe I
thought I don't know if this is the
right thing for me but as I thought
about it I really I really loved the
show it was more of a competition
reality show about music and I loved
music so much and it's such a big part
of my life and I knew I would have
something to contribute to it so I felt
like it would be a good way to kind of
reintroduce myself back into to the
business again into the public eye oh no
it was brought to tears many times at
American Idol you know it was an
emotional show about people's dreams and
struggles and and what they would do to
get there and the things that they had
gone through in their life that inspired
their their artistry and their music
monster not working with Jane Fonda was
amazing she's an amazing actress
obviously and she had left the business
for about ten years
and so it was her first movie back and
she was very excited said that she did
the movie to work with me which was
crazy I was like really I've never
thought of myself in that way but she
was amazing in the movie and we had the
best time working together the cake
scene I remember you know her kind of
putting my head in the cake I remember
her falling asleep in the stew you know
different funny moments that we had on
the set that were really great Elka
nothing and gone Dante was the first
movie that I produced so it was a big
deal for me I was putting this movie
together
that was a musical I knew that mark who
I was married to at the time would play
and always knew that even before we were
married cuz I always was trying to
develop that script but it was a it was
a special project and it was a special
character for me to play - yeah yeah I
did at the time I felt like both Mark
and I it's a very difficult thing for a
real-life couple to play on-screen and
be convincing as the characters and I
felt he was so convincing as Hector
Lavoe and I was so convincing as his
wife and just because of the fact that
it was a low-budget movie and we didn't
have the money to market it and promote
it in the right way that maybe it got
overlooked a little bit but you know we
haven't been straight for more than
three hours a day for about 20 years but
since we met
and we just go on with life like this
honestly it's a flawed movie I don't
think it was a perfect movie but I do
believe that the performance is by
marking myself or something that I am
very proud of to this day out of sight
working with Steven Soderbergh was such
a great experience for me
I found him to be so clever and so smart
he's one of the few directors I've ever
worked with I've done I don't know how
many movies over 30 movies or something
like that he was the only one who would
like come up and just sit next to you in
the scene by the camera
he wouldn't watch a monitor he just
wanted to see your face and feel the
energy of what was happening between the
actors at that moment I just loved that
experience of working with the director
I always remember that about him it was
a great part for me I think it marked
like where I was kind of you know
leading lady status that was really
special to others
my character in hustlers is named Ramona
she's you know a bit of a of an
entrepreneur I like to say she's a
single mom from the Bronx who is a
stripper and has been in the strip club
game for many many years and during the
crash of 2008 you know decided that she
needed to be a little bit more
enterprising and figure out a way to
make money where and when nobody was
making money in that business she's kind
of a mama bear and it's scary and kind
of a pimp at the same time so she's
unpredictable
you don't know what you're gonna get
with her you could get a lot of love or
you can get a slap in the face it just
depends if you mess with her money or
not money is her is her main main
objective it was because I've never been
somebody and people would be like oh
yeah right but I've never been motivated
by money
I've always been motivated by I want to
be a great actress of great singer a
great dancer I'm gonna make movies I
want to make music and the money came
along with that and now that people know
that you have money they go oh yeah
right you know but I'm not and I'm still
to this day not so to play a character I
do things because I love them I didn't
get paid a whole bunch of money for
hustler I did it for free and produced
it a bank on myself you know as a
Jennifer black she does I do what I want
I do what I love but um I was kind of a
really different mindset to get into to
play Ramona I had never been somebody
who was kind of that bad this person was
really unapologetically savage when it
came to what she wanted and that was a
brand new thing for me it was fun when I
was playing it it was scary when I was
watching it
obviously for the pole-dancing and you
know to be playing a stripper you know
it was gonna be showing a lot of skin
and in my body so in a way that I hadn't
ever before so it was a lot of training
and strength training and then pole
dancing training and it was really
really difficult
what if you don't have muscles to do
that you have muscles to do this I don't
have and every girl has muscles to do
this this London is the martini
firemen down
I visited a lot of strip club not a lot
of strip clubs a few strip clubs I
talked to a few girls and I got what I
needed from the experience and I think
people have a perception that they're
ashamed of it or it's something they
want to hide or it's something that you
know they should feel bad about and they
don't they're like we're dancers we
dance for money we're proud of our
bodies I feel fine
I mean there's this little bit of a
bravado and it takes balls to get up
there so you know it takes a you know a
lot of strength
I found one playing my character some
damage there and so again these are not
simple characters they're very complex
with a lot of things going on inside of
them and I think that's why people are
responding to Ramona because she had so
many different colors in the sense or
lack of a better word at different
dimensions I was a center for once
93 oh my gosh
like when Stevie Wonder came in well
Stevie Wonder coming to go as a producer
it's super satisfying to me that people
love the movie you know that there's
been such a great response to it that
women especially and then by the way
love this movie I've heard so many girls
going I'm going with five of my
girlfriends I'm going me and all the
girls from the office are going and
that's kind of Bennett's it became like
a movement it wasn't just a movie it was
just like this is our movie where we run
[ __ ] they know it's all women producers
women director women writer all women
starring in it and they kind of took
ownership of that we've been watching
men take advantage of women in movies a
long time and so it was a fun kind of
ride to see the table's turned I don't
know I mean it would be nice but we'll
see I mean I'm really happy that people
even have me in that conversation that
feels good that feels really good
[Music]